i'm going to start at the beginning
let's talk about
samuel the investor where you started
and the man
and i'll ask the question talk us
through your first
property how did you finance it how did
you buy it
why did you buy it over to you great
question
i've never actually spoke too much about
my first property and i
am quite soon going to be doing a video
on youtube specifically about my very
first property so this could be
absolutely fresh off the press right now
because our first property it's
interesting
because it was it was i bought it when i
was 17 years old
and the reason i bought it when i was 17
years old is because
i was looking i knew i wanted to be a
property investor literally
three six months after leaving school i
was like i wanna buy i wanna buy a
property i wanna
i wanna do monopoly in real life i wanna
i wanna have money working for me i
wanna
have freedom i wanna build an empire for
a new one to do it but in my mind
even though i was getting training and i
was going on courses and stuff
and then everyone was saying this was
back in 2008 by the way
everyone was saying you can buy houses
without using any of your own money
there's
there's back-to-back lending there's um
same-day refinance for mortgage express
you can raise finance you can joint
venture and i was thinking
this is great i believe i can do this
i was 17. in my mind i had to be 18 to
own a house so i'm learning everything
i'm a sponge and it was it was only when
my
mortgage broker told me that you have to
be 21 to get a buy to let mortgage and
suddenly now
that's like a knife knife in my chest
i'm thinking man i've got to wait
four years before i can buy a house that
sucks
even though i'm learning all these
strategies i've invested all of my paper
money going on courses i've got to wait
four years
and i was i was thinking about it and
then and then i thought well actually if
i stick it in someone else's name
maybe i can maybe i can buy a house at
18. and then i thought well hold on i'm
17.
if i stick it to someone else's name i
could do it right now
so it was it was kind of the the
obstacle the dagger in the chest
that actually helped me and enabled me
to get my first property when i was 17.
so how i bought it
it was on um on the maryvale road in
birmingham bourneville
i still own the house i still own the
house today and it was
by the time i actually completed on it
was the week before my 18th birthday
and i was i was 17 years old and i
bought it with the banks money it was it
was it was a no money down
um um property where you buy it we
financed the same day i bought it for a
hundred thousand pounds
we financed it the same day 120
um pulled the money out i did it in my
step dad's name he didn't give me any
money but he just let me let me host the
property
and everyone was saying to me at the
time property markets crashing right now
what are you
doing it's going to go down the
properties are going to be worth 5
thousand pounds
um people are saying to me that's a bad
time what are you doing getting all
these
mentors and getting all these courses
why don't you just go to university and
spend 40 000 pounds learning about art
you know that that's people's mindset so
a lot of people were against me the
press were against me at the time not
against me as a person but against the
idea of being a buy to that landlord
everyone was saying viceland is dead
bought the house my mortgage payments
were 166 pounds per month
on that little house and what i did and
i could literally write a book on my
first house
what i did was i rented it out room by
room
as a multi-let at the time i didn't know
what i was doing i didn't know that
um this was a hmo and this was i just
thought actually you know what
if i rent it out by the room i'll get
more rent there was two reception rooms
three bedrooms i turned one of the
reception rooms into a bedroom by
literally putting a bed in it not
complicated
and the rent was 1400 pounds a month
the mortgage was 166 pounds a month
i'm managing it myself making about a
thousand pounds profit a month
so everyone's saying it's gonna go down
now the property did start going down
and i was i was thinking ooh but then it
bounced back up
now the house is worth 215 thousand
pounds approximately so i made a hundred
thousand pounds
equity but i've also i recently
calculated that i've made over a hundred
thousand pounds profit in rent over the
last
12 years so that little house has made
me two
000 pounds profit over
just shy of 12 years and everyone told
me i was stupid and i shouldn't buy it
it's now in my own name i've switched it
from my stepdad's name to my name
and um yeah that's that's the story of
my very first house
and obviously i went and did many many
more that was the very first one
but that house alone replaced
my income for a 16 17 year old like
that little house so that's that that
was when
after that property you know i just i
just went crazy i just went hardcore
um but that was my first one 12 years
ago so you've lost your property
investment virginity
there at a young age of 17. my hat's off
to you for doing that i appreciate that
so you said that you went on and went
nuts so
all right let's talk about it how did
you grow that portfolio where did you
get your money from how what types of
property did you go
for you know actually can you include in
this answer what sort of targets you had
for yourself or what pro
what sort of profits you wanted to
achieve that sort of thing
so my target at the time there was two
there was two things there was two
targets and there was a personal there
was a personal goal
and a personal feeling and then there
was also um a business
a business goal the business goal
was at the time literally it sounds like
it sounds like nothing and
i achieved it quite quickly i just
wanted i just wanted to make i just want
to make two and a half thousand pounds a
month
in passive income that was my initial
goal um
it actually took me quite a long time to
do that because although my first house
was making me a thousand pounds a month
that was a hmo after that i bought some
single lets
and the profit on that was quite small
monthly so it took me
took me a few you know a good few years
to to
to um you know to be making good money
from property but to be making a living
i did it quite quick
um my personal goal was i wanted to
travel i wanted to
um i'd recently uh become a christian
and my church i was working with my
church
and and i wanted to go out on some on
some trips with my church
i wanted to um help building schools in
rural parts of africa bringing water to
villages um you know i wanted to help
working orphanages in in the slums of
india like i just had a real i did have
a genuine real passion
to help people and to give um but but on
top of that
i also got a real i don't know what it
was like
a massive sense of achievement when i'd
get the keys to a house so the fact
owning a house you know as a teenager i
was a bit of a dropout school i didn't
do well in school and i just think the
sense of achievement i got from being
like i own that house
for me and some of the houses that i
bought when i was a teenager
they weren't that great the first one as
it happens was great but some of the
other ones
they're okay might make me 150 quid a
month but the sense of
achievement that i got from it the
confidence that it gave me
that was like myself that that my
self-esteem was made in property you
know
didn't do well in school my parents flew
up when i was seven years old it was a
really nice to split up
my brother was always better than me at
sport at school he would be you know so
i was
like knocking my brother's shadow or
anything but he was a smart one
better academics better at sport faster
so so for me like actually being able to
make money in poverty
that kind of gave me a real sense of
achievement um
so i guess that was really that was
really my you know my goals that was
what made me tick